[Music]
all right so tell us if you recognize
the script if it sounds familiar
Donald Trump has violated vital and
cherished norms in this country he has
lowered America's moral tone he has
turned our national conversation into a
tawdry slideshow fit for the New York
Post hear that a lot in the media
sometimes people yell it at you they
seem entirely convinced it's true
certainly the ladies of the view are
convinced is true and today they decided
to fight back and make this country a
little more wholesome how do they do
that well they give three segments of
their show to a newly minted political
pundit who has spent her career having
sex with strangers for money along for
the ride was her creepy porn lawyer who
even by his own low standards and we
know a lot about it was especially
creepy today watch this comments from
Tucker Carlson and some of these other
pigs that are men that make these
comments that that belong in the fish
you say that pigs are the smartest
animal no man should be making comments
like that about a woman period so don't
invite that guy over to babysit not that
you'd probably consider it but also now
he's not going away and this is the key
thing to know about the creepy porn
lawyer he may be running for president
how's that possible you ask ask the
people who are promoting him on
television he's their perfect candidate
he says more about them than about
himself
Jamie Bruce is in New York radio show
host and president of independent
woman's voice and she joins us tonight
Tammy every time we do a creepy
important lawyer segment I think boy I
hope we're not encouraging or promoting
the guy but then I look over at the view
and they're literally encouraging and
promoting him do you think they feel
reckless doing that yeah look I think
that it says all kinds of things about
them you know we see what the attitude
is of that man and his client and yet
you know they're kind of opportunistic
entrepreneurs because of the notoriety
of her accusations against the president
she has appearances at strip clubs
across the country and they sell out and
there's a lot of money and and I don't
know how she's paying
mr. avenatti the creepy porn lawyer but
I think he has an interest of course in
in that profile remaining high in this
nation we usually have a word for men
who do encourage women to sell
themselves for sex maybe the women of
the view should ask for a piece of the
money that's being made in the process
of her notoriety now I'm not one to tell
women how to make a living
here's what we do know we know that
pornography itself degrades women it
resends a message to society that women
are to be used like dirty dish rags that
you that buying and selling women is
normal for sexual gratification and that
is something that Americans reject we
reject it for our daughters and our
wives and our girlfriends and our
sisters and our moms so this is not to
be normalized it's insulting to suggest
that it should be and until you've got a
five-year-old he says mommy when I grow
up I want to be a porn star we know that
little girls have different dreams and
and different ideas of what they can
become now for stormy Daniels this is
what works for her and we can all you
know we all find our level we can all
determine it in that regard what she's
doing III would love the creepy porn
Lorie to run for president because it
reminds us what the left has become now
you he called you a pig little did we
know that now men who would come out and
suggest that we could live better lives
and treat women better that now that is
the biggest piggish position who saw
that coming right - everything is or
everything is very well in I'd like
knowing questions for you but that was
so good I couldn't stop Tammy's got to
see you tonight thanks for having me
sure